sky news has witnessed some of the
conditions that people in eastern
ukraine have been living in since the
start of the war many have been
sheltering and cold damp bunkers for two
months now
coming out only for food and medical
treatment well joining us
from la viv in western ukraine is world
hope health organization spokesperson
banu bhatnagar uh really good to talk to
you today you saw a little bit there of
alex rossi going into the underground
bunkers we saw in alex's report that the
hospital that he'd visited had been
attacked 20 times and was attacked again
just a short time after he left it uh
what is the latest that you know about
the situation there in that area and
that hospital
thank you yes so watcho has been uh
trying to reach that hospital uh it's
the only functioning hospital uh in uh
siberia genetic at the moment um we we
were able to reach with supplies uh
recently we we had offered them a large
generator so that they at least would
have uh power to to treat their patients
but in fact the generator was so large
and that they were worried it would
become an object of attack because it
would have had to sit outside the
hospital and would have been you know
you could have seen it from the air so
we instead gave them a smaller electric
generator that they could place inside
their basement so that they could
continue uh to operate we're talking
about a pretty dire situation there's
about a hundred patients uh still in
that hospital and as you're reporting uh
has um as your reporter has said it's
come under attack multiple times some
doctors have left we understand nurses
are are essentially taking on the duties
of doctors uh we also understand that
the general community the people in the
in the community are coming to to help
the hospital to fix broken windows to
clean the hallways
so that it can continue to operate but
it's absolutely vital that there's some
sort of a humanitarian ceasefire so we
can actually get more supplies in uh
where we also understand there's there's
a lack of medicines blood pressure
medicines simple painkillers uh to keep
things like fever uh down uh so so it
really is vital that that uh suppliers
can get in
um and in terms of you obviously want to
get supplies in but also there'll be
people there who want to get out as well
what assistance are you able to offer
so as i said we've been calling for a
humanitarian ceasefire for for weeks now
the secretary general is actually in uh
ukraine at the moment and uh
we hope uh that there can be some sort
of a humanitarian ceasefire to get
people out of severe dynast but also
mariopol which has been besieged for for
so long
we as w as who as the world health
organization we need to be able to get
inside to actually assess health needs
it's one thing moving supplies
near
to places that are seeing some of the
heavy fighting but we're in a way
guessing what supplies are needed and
for the most part i'm sure our supplies
will be used but we actually need to get
inside to understand what the actual
needs are are we talking about
conflict-related injuries
do we do we have people with
non-communicable diseases or chronic
conditions that need care like diabetes
cardiovascular disease cancer hiv
patients
so it's absolutely vital that there's
some sort of a humanitarian ceasefire
and we need to see it for a minimum of
two days
so that supplies can move in and people
can come out
and how hopeful are you are that any
kind of humanitarian ceasefire can be
reached
so that's a political decision uh as i'm
sure you know and and uh
who and other un agencies continue to
to lobby and and negotiate with with all
parties and to ensure uh that uh that a
humanitarian ceasefire can be agreed
upon as i said the secretary general is
here uh and and his presence here uh is
is important uh the un is ready to
mobilize the entire uh organization in
order to get people out of mariupol
safely but also ensure that supplies can
reach safely to places that need it
well best of luck with that banu
bantengar from the world health
organization thank you very much